let's talk about waves
so let's imagine that you were to take a
string and attach it at one end to a
wall and then on the other end you were
to wiggle it up and down
well then you would have made a wave you
would see a pattern that looks like this
now what could be a good definition for
a wave well we could call it a traveling
disturbance well what does that mean
well we're disturbing the rope if we
didn't move it if we just held it
straight it might look something like
that or it might just hang down a little
bit but clearly we are now moving it up
and down and those movements are
disturbing that rope and that
disturbance can move along that rope now
we see waves not just in ropes that are
moving up and down you have probably
seen water waves if you were to take a
tank of water like this and if you were
to start pressing on one end of the
water here you would see these wave
forms that start
we can also see that with sound and
sound waves you might not realize it but
the sound of my voice right now is
actually just a traveling compression or
disturbance in the air that is getting
to your ear and then little hairs in
your ears can sense those changes in
pressure from the air and your mind
perceives that as sound and once again
this is a traveling disturbance you have
particles that have high pressure and
then they knock into the particles next
to them that then knock into the
particles next to them so if you were to
be able to observe this in slow motion
you would see these high pressure parts
right over here could be traveling say
to the right and even though this might
be a pressure wave that's traveling
through the air we can represent it in a
way that looks a lot like our first rope
that we were moving up and down
areas where things are high in the sound
example that's high pressure and you
have areas where things are low in the
sound example that is low pressure now
when we talk about waves they're common
properties for example we might want to
know how much are we getting disturbed
from what we would call the equilibrium
you could view that as maybe the middle
state right over there
well if we're getting disturbed that
much we could call that the amplitude
that's how much we are going
above or below that equilibrium this
would be the amplitude as well
we could think about how far is it from
the same points on the wave so if we go
from one peak to another peak
well we could call that the wavelength
and you could just do it from any one
point on the wave that's just like it on
the wave again so that would be the same
wavelength as our original wavelength
right over there you might hear the term
frequency of a wave and one way to think
about that is if you were to just
observe our original rope and if you
were to say how many times does it go
all the way up all the way down and then
back up so it completes a full cycle how
many times can it do that in a second if
it does that five times in a second then
someone might say it has a frequency of
five cycles per second
now everything that we have just talked
about these are called mechanical waves
it's a special category probably the
ones that you will see most often now
mechanical waves need a medium to travel
through in the rope example the medium
was the rope in the water example it's
the water in the sound example the
medium is the air
now there are things that can be
described as waves that don't need a
medium
in particular and this is kind of
mind-boggling is that light can be
considered a wave if we think about the
different frequencies of light our brain
perceives that as different colors and
if we think about the amplitude of light
our brain perceives that as the
intensity of light how bright it is and
even more mind-blowing visible light are
just certain frequencies of what we
would call
electromagnetic waves there's actually
higher frequencies of electromagnetic
waves that have all sorts of
applications you might have heard of
ultraviolet light or x-rays or gamma
rays
similarly their lower wavelengths of
light you might have heard things like
infrared or radio waves these are all
just different frequencies of what's
known as
electromagnetic waves